hey everybody and welcome back to parka
texts let's just get right into it so
today we have mystic oasis which is my
personal favorite of the scenarios which
have worked on its well the description
sells it pretty well actually a fun fact
for a lot of these scenarios I made up
sort of a document with different
descriptions of the scenarios and what I
sort of expected from them in terms of
difficulty rating things like that so
they were slightly rearranged from my
list but to a large extent and also
fitting in the different scenarios also
by Joshua it's pretty much the list as I
also set it up and for all of the
different scenarios I also just added a
small description for it so on some of
these scenarios the text that you see
over here was written by me maybe with a
few slight adjustments but yeah that's
also one of them the nice little tidbits
I suppose that I could talk about anyway
the goal is to get four hundred guests
in the park and it's not really the
highest guest goal so far but as you'll
see the map is really quite small
actually why am I talking about this
here I might as well just get into the
map and show you while I'm at it so yeah
we have a very small Oasis basically and
the theme is sort of Arab and yeah we
have this really small map here so it's
not altogether a very difficult scenario
but at this point the challenge is also
going to be to make sure that we fit it
in with the map that we get and for some
of the other challenges we need to make
sure that the happiness rating is 75%
and oh god I don't exactly remember what
I did with this one I I just remembered
that I also put up you know some small
notes that you don't actually see here
regarding you know what other challenges
there sort of are in the park
and I think among them was actually that
you know the guests even though they're
rich they're not very easily entertained
so the happiness rating might not be as
easy to get as other parks but then
again as long as there are rides and
nothing is broken down and there's no
big vandalism or anything like that I'm
pretty sure that the happiness rating
isn't that difficult to get right and
but that's probably something fun to
look into maybe after I do this scenario
so I don't you know completely cheats
myself on this here but yeah the
optional goals are just to have one
hundred and two hundred guests in the
park I don't know what the rewards for
that are gonna be like again for a lot
of these scenarios even though I might
have set up some of the goals I
definitely you know for one there have
been a lot of changes and I also don't
remember a lot of stuff especially since
this was one of the earlier scenarios if
I remember correctly so I must have made
this you know nearly a year ago or
something like that so I'm pretty much
starting off with a blank slate here in
any case I think it's about time that I
just start building some stuff I think
the style that you sort of start off
with with the entrance even though it's
really simple and it's really just this
entrance building over here it's a nice
style to sort of keep going with in the
rest of the park although it is quite
limited so I'm gonna try and be a bit
creative with what other kinds of
elements I use I should be able to at
least have a decent set of scenery to
make that happen yeah so well before we
do the rest actually let's finally look
into what rights we have so it's pretty
limited actually I could probably put a
small boat right here but that's about
it
I do remember I was actually
specifically requested to raise the
water in this pond it was originally up
to half heights which I did quite a lot
but in order to actually build water
rights on to the water you need to have
a full height and the height one doesn't
allow any water rights so that's
something to also keep in mind but the
rides are pretty simple we've got the
magic carpets of course I mean that just
fits in perfectly but aside from that I
think I'll do a little bit of research
in some kind of flat rides but really
just get started from here on out and if
I also remember correctly I throw rights
probably the best idea if I also
remember correctly we eventually get
yeah we already start off with your
vertical drop coaster actually so we
already start off with what's probably
my favourite coaster type in the game so
I definitely want to try and focus on
this
and get a cool layout for the vertical
drop coaster in so yeah without further
ado let's finally get started alright
now that was a pretty long intro so I'm
going to make this quite a long time
lapse as well until I get a good grasp
of what the park is going to look like
and by the end of this we'll have quite
a bit of scenery and a lot of stuff to
talk about to be completely honest
actually I ended up detailing this way
more than I was expecting to and you
know even though I am doing these
episodes you know bit by bits so I'm
recording a time-lapse and then I'm
commentating over its then I'm getting
back to real-time etc so I have no idea
what the end of this episode is gonna be
like I think this is gonna be a really
long one again and I know I keep telling
you that I'm gonna try to keep these
things shorts but it just it doesn't
happen I couldn't stop myself from
detailing this park even more than I
detailed the Western roundup and coral
caldera and why it's not it's nice to
have that sort of you know progression
over time and what the parks look like I
do need to watch out with that I think
because right now it's still doable
because the scenarios are nice and easy
but eventually I might run into issues
with this for now though the reason that
I can't stop myself from detailing these
things way too much and why these
episodes are becoming really long and
also pretty frequent in terms of my
upload rate it's simply just because
I've been enjoying this game way too
much I I just love playing it so yeah
that's that but yeah this maybe I should
talk about what I'm building actually
that might be a pretty good idea so
obviously I do want to stick to the
theme of the entrance building and you
know we're in the deserts we've got some
kind of Arabian or Islamic kind of a
theme here so that's mostly what I'm
going to try to follow so I wanted to
build a Main Street in the style of a
bazaar so some kind of marketplace or a
street with lots of commercial activity
which is a nice way to give it a bit
more Flair and a bit more detail than
you otherwise would because
realistically building a sort of Arabian
desert village it would end
looking pretty boring I guess it would
just be a lot of sandstone and simple
square closed buildings just because
that's sort of what works for that
natural environments in real life but
for a theme park you know we need to
switch things up a little bit and really
just sell a very commodified idea of
Arabian architecture and something
that's a bit more flashy and interesting
so I'm still going with all the the
simple sandstone buildings as you would
expect in this kind of setting but with
a lot more color on the details and
because of that I'm putting all of these
awnings and different doors and in a
little bit as well some planters and
stuff like that in here just to make
sure that we can get some color and some
interesting you know aspects of this as
well so then it's not all boring and I
have to say over here as well a lot of
inspiration here it came from the
Arabian coast area of Tokyo DisneySea
which is honestly absolutely one of my
favorite themed areas of any theme park
in the world and honestly it's already
my favorite theme park in the world so
yeah that's that's one of my favorite
places I've only been there twice but
every time I've been there it's just
been no I'm just shocked whenever I
enter that area just at how well themed
and well laid out it is it isn't even
that big but there are just so many
little nooks and crannies and small
streets to explore and at the same time
you've got these large palaces and domes
and minarets sort of towering over
everything and then it's all just
connected by this beautiful palm tree
heavy lush foliage that you know you
have throughout the entire area it's
just absolutely beautiful
so a huge inspiration here and to be
completely honest it's also what
inspired me to actually you know go a
bit more boldly with the colors because
before I was looking into that as a sort
of inspiration and still thinking of
maybe trying to go for a more realistic
route I you know I was planning to make
everything a bit more beige and
colorless and in hindsight having all of
these green and red and orange and
bright blue details everywhere it
really helps to make it look a little
bit more interesting so yeah it might
not be the most realistic thing because
in the end it is sort of a theme-park
version of Arabian architecture but I
hope you can understand that you know to
some extent I do want to also emulate
how theme parks look in general and
while it's easy to sort of get lost in
any kind of particular architectural
style in the end theme parks aren't you
know really architecture in the the
classic sense of architecture it's it's
it's almost more like design really than
architecture just trying to sell a
certain look rather than trying design
buildings and in fact if you look at it
a lot of buildings in theme parks aren't
actually buildings but just facades but
yeah that's a that's a bit of a tangent
for another day perhaps for this Main
Street I always basically planning to
make it all simple buildings but with
one little thing at the end just to you
know look at something while you're
walking at the Main Street have
something cool in the background you
could call it a weenie if you will it's
something like the Disney Castle but a
little bit smaller and it's a bit more
subtle you know because we're not
building Disney here so basically it's
it's a sort of temple ish inspired well
I should say a mosque probably but it's
I don't actually have the cultural
knowledge to know exactly what it'd be
like but yeah this building over here
with a dome and the spire that's pretty
cool and pretty colorful and a pretty
big draw I think for the Main Street as
well and it also doubles as the entrance
of the teacups ride which is quite handy
because if there's one thing that I've
learned from Tokyo DisneySea it is that
dressing up the entrances of rides or
something you know else that's
interesting as these really grandiose
palace like structures works really well
to actually divert people into those
places so if I remember the the theatre
for instance that you have there which
has an amazing show which is in Japanese
I barely could understand anything but
it's still really funny and amazing but
yeah the theatre over there is just this
big palace with the
this inner courtyard as well and it just
draws you toward it just to know what it
is even if you don't know that that
particular ride is there having your
rides dressed up as something like that
just works because it draws people to
that area and then once you're there you
know you can always find out what it is
it works well on a map as well I guess
because you can very well represent the
structure on the map and make that very
recognizable as well but yeah overall it
just works out really well so that's why
I'm putting this over the teacups and
then the choice for the teacups
specifically you know maybe it's not the
most Arabian theme I don't know I feel
like this some extent a lot of different
cultures in the world have claimed tea
but in any case it's it's just a ride
that I think works out really well
because it's a right that I want to be
covered anyway a lot of them are covered
and if you're using a covered right
might as well turn it into something
that works as a building for the main
street as well now my next sort of
little urban design issue here was that
the Main Street was almost looking like
a sort of Enclave on its own so I built
that little you know protruding area
with the umbrellas and the benches just
to have a bit more of a connection with
the rest of the park you know sort of
transition from the Main Street into the
rest of the park and I think it helps a
little bit with that I'm definitely
gonna dress it up more in the future
put some bushes and stuff over there
some kind of detail but for now I wanted
to move on and I'm actually not moving
on in the direction of the Oasis itself
I want to try and keep the Oasis clear
actually and I mean I'm not too
knowledgeable about this subject from
but from what I've generally seen a lot
of these sort of Oasis villages they
won't be built on the actual Oasis
itself which is sort of on the border of
it and it was probably some kind of
geographical reason for it
that I'm not really too aware of but I
think it just works out really well to
have all of the buildings and structures
sort of around the Oasis but keep the
Oasis as a sort of more clear a natural
centerpiece of the park almost like a
theme park that structured around the
lake kind of like I was talking about in
Victoria Lake but a bit different this
time because we're in the desert but
yeah we're gonna have this more town
setting again over here
slightly different pavements texture
because I was just feeling bored of the
old texture but I'm up to the same
shenanigans basically just building
squares and rectangles in sandstone
colors and then dressing it up with
small details to make things look a bit
more interesting and colorful I should
also note a very small tip that really
works out I think in cases like this is
to give all the buildings slightly
different shades so for all of these
buildings I would take the pipette tool
and just click on an older building and
then just slightly move the color just
to make sure that all of the buildings
have generally the same kind of
sandstone color to them but because
they're all pretty much textualist and
they're all interconnected you wouldn't
be able to tell where one building ends
in one building begins again so they all
have a slightly different shade if that
sort of sandstone color which I think
works out quite well in this case and
normally this isn't to importance but
given the sort of theme with all these
different no similarly the sized and
shaped buildings in very similar colors
I think little my new differences like
this can help out to make everything
look a little bit nicer now over here I
should probably address the fact that
I'm building a roller coaster all of a
sudden over here I decided to build the
vertical trough coaster and I know I
call it the vertical drop coaster
because it's called that in game but
really in real life this is the the girl
our Eurofighter which is not the
favorite roller coaster of many roller
coaster enthusiasts but honestly I have
to say it's one of my favourite coasters
even though they're not the most
comfortable thing they just manage to do
so much with an insanely compact layout
and this one I think is no different you
move into that loop in the beginning
then into a quick helix and a little bit
of airtime actually into any moment over
there and then finally twisting back and
forth to go into a barrel roll at the
end and well I think works out about
this layouts is that it's a pretty
common sort of flow of elements for a
Eurofighter they almost always start out
with a vertical loop after the drop and
then
some kind of turnaround elements and
then at the end they always have these
sort of helix sections with barrel rolls
but in this case the layout is a little
bit more spread out than most
Eurofighter is because I wanted to make
sure that it sort of had this skyline
feature that's built around the lake and
then the rest of the park will be built
sort of at the foot of the layouts of
the coaster it's also totally not
efficient and I hope that this thing is
actually gonna make me enough money
because there are no mid-course brake
runs in the middle of the layouts and
even though the coaster is quite short
as these things are very typically are
as well having a mid-course brake run in
the middle of the layout would have
really helped out on efficiency reasons
but to be completely honest I skipped
out on it just because I thought it
looks better with this layouts so yeah I
hope that is not going to fire back at
me because I would really like to keep
this Park and I would really like to not
go bankrupt but I think it'll be all
right now over here I'm just building
another bizarre again a slight my new
differences on the texture of the paths
as well just because that just looks so
nice and this this almost kind of
gallery ish look at the beside here this
is very heavily inspired also by Tokyo
DisneySea
what else creating these sort of inner
courtyards with these symmetrical
gardens in this case it's not much of a
symmetrical garden it's just two great
spaces but you know it's something
something at least it's also not
entirely symmetrical but you get the
idea and putting a helter-skelter over
here actually I know it's not called
that in game but I mean this is just
what these things are called for me in
my head anyway I just think it works out
quite nicely to have that here because
it's sitting sort of on that corner
between the two parts of the Oasis sort
of overlooking it's almost like a
lighthouse ish and yeah I wanted to put
the flat rides just like the buildings
mostly up from the Oasis itself and
keeping all of that lush green foliage
and the little ponds
more or less intact so we've got that
pretty simple and after that I wanted to
move into finishing the square and
finally of course with finishing the
square comes working on this station of
the coaster which is gonna be a bit of a
challenge actually it's it's it's
heavily inspired by Tokyo Disney sees
Arabian coasts a themed area you might
have heard of it somebody might have
talked about it at some point in the
past it's a pretty nice area I think but
yeah it has these big palaces that you
know services the entrances and exits to
some of the rides and in this case you
know this is the star attraction of the
park this is gonna be it there's not
gonna be anything that's better than
this if this is all you came for for
this video you might as well click this
video away because it's not gonna get
better from here we're just gonna have
this this coaster and rest it up as
nicely as possible with a slightly
bombastic sort of Palace look to it so
of course building a tower here on the
side and I wanted to you know have some
slight detail on it you know this is the
the starship ride of the park so this is
also gonna be the most important
building so it's gonna have a big Tower
and lots of arches and also these these
basic shapes as cornerstones and
honestly the the shapes work out really
well for really anything that you'd want
to try and build with them so I can
definitely recommend just making these
shapes really small and see how you can
make certain details on buildings with
them because it's it's really quite
handy and then for some of the other
pieces I'm also just repurposing pieces
from other sets so the arches are
actually castle arches but I think that
combined with the pillars especially
sort of the the ones surrounding the
square that we have in front of this
building it almost looks like the
Arabian sort of onion shaped arch not
quite but I mean it's close enough
there's no Arabian theme in the game but
I still think you can get pretty close
to it with all of the different pieces
that we have so yeah that works out
quite alright and then finally the dome
on the station building just to top that
off
and yeah I think it's a pretty good
built so far now I want to go back into
a real time section just to see how this
actually works so let's see if we can
actually make this park profitable well
as it turns out the park runs a lot
better than I expected so I'm making
$800 profit a month I can actually
unfreeze this I did have a bit of an
unlucky thing with the the research so
as far as I understand the stuff that
you get in the research is sort of
randomized so you never know what you're
gonna get out of your research and in my
case my research team decided to start
researching researching the jumper ride
which is actually the write that I got
for my challenge goal of having 100
guests in the park so that's a bit of a
shame but it's not too much of a problem
I mean I still have a bunch of other
rides that I can place but yeah I've got
the jumper now as well definitely want
to place the wipe out somewhere and of
course I can't miss out on the magic
carpets but basically the reason that
the park has been doing so well is
pretty much the coaster of course it's
not the the typical flat rides it
doesn't even have a terrible throughput
which I feel like is sort of typical for
these Euro fighters in general you tend
to think that they're really bad when it
comes to throughput but I mean this four
people per row and they do have that
vertical lift tail so they they don't
have to stall too much on the lift on
which is nice and this one specifically
yeah it's making about 900 dollars of
profits a month so that's really good
actually and that's where a lot of my
money is coming from right now the stats
are actually quite good as well it's not
something that I typically tend to look
at too much but obviously since I'm
playing scenario right now I do want to
focus on making good stats but it's got
an extreme excitement up to only a
medium intensity and alone or generating
so that's the super good actually I
haven't come up with a name yet and I
still need to finish this because I do
want to put more scenery over here and I
definitely want to fill up the queue all
of those poor guests are currently
waiting in the the heat of the Sun of
the Desert Sun so that's a bit painful I
suppose but all together not doing too
shabby indeed and there is something
that I gathered from the comments as
well that I should do better one of them
is that I forgot to put trash chutes
into my older parks so normally your
employees are gonna have to put the
trash somewhere and you can also hook
those up to the pipe system which brings
the deliveries to shops and I forgot to
do that for my other scenarios so that's
something that I'm gonna have to keep in
mind for this one if it grows a little
bit more but right now I think I am fine
with the employees and the employee
paths that I have right now
all that I do have to worry about is
vandalism because I can already see some
stuff breaking down but I think
altogether it's not doing too bad so my
next plan is to maybe fill up a little
bit more of this area maybe not quite
with rides but you know some stuff and
also start expanding the park into this
direction and given the the fact that
I'm still getting some guests are still
going into the park I think that with a
little bit of expansion on this side and
another coaster or two coasters I should
be able to reach the guests go of 400
guests
not to mention that so far I haven't
done any advertising on any of my
scenarios yet and that's something that
I can still do - yeah there we go some
campaigns that's something that I can
still actually do to make sure that I
get the goal because I do want to keep
this part quite small I think a nice and
compact layout just around the Oasis
with lots of small buildings and flat
rides place very close to each other I
think that just works out really well
for this park so even though the map is
really small I don't think I'm going to
even use all of it although for the
coaster I was glad to have a bit of
space over here because it just barely
fits into the size that we've got but
yeah let's get started again and start
building some stuff all right
now first and foremost I want to dress
up the area around the Eurofighter a
little bit because this whole you know
purely desert theme this is just not
gonna do and for now I decided to put
this little area next to the East
winging ship because there wasn't quite
enough space to put a ride there and it
always helps to just put these little
areas around the park
just get some benches or a little place
to relax something for either
introverted people like me who just want
to sit somewhere and watch stuff go or
you know maybe your your grandma's
coming along with the family and she
wants to wait and when everybody's in
the swinging shape either way these
little areas with you know some seats
especially around coasters and flat
rides where you can start watching stuff
is always pretty nice so I decided to
built that there and then the
Eurofighter itself definitely needs a
lot of scenery I also wanted to focus on
trying to make all the queues as covered
as I can because the climate is really
hot so you could see it's sunny and it's
39 degrees Celsius right now which for
the Americans out there that's that's
really hot I don't know the exact
conversion but that is definitely
deserts temperatures and then for the
lift Hill I did want to make this look a
little bit more like an actual
Eurofighter so in real life these things
always get these while these big support
structures like this a little bit more
narrow but given the grid spaces of
Architects it's a tiny bit off but it's
still pretty good to go it at least and
helps to sort of put these supports
there quickly just to make it look a
little bit more like an actual
Eurofighter and then for the loop as
well I wanted to add some extra supports
to that I eventually ended up going with
the castle pillars because they're
completely round and they have almost
the exact same shape and size as the
actual coaster supports so that's pretty
heavy
and as a little off-topic notes and this
is something that I haven't talked about
very much but I sometimes see it popping
up in common so I think it's a good idea
to address it at least quickly I am
playing the game completely without mods
just because I want to play the
scenarios vanilla on the one hand mods
can kind of you know help out give you
some other scenery pieces and stuff that
you otherwise wouldn't have but I also
just want to show off the game on its
own merits I might get into moderate
later if I ever get into a sandbox park
or something like that but for now I'm
keeping everything vanilla so yeah
that's something to keep in mind now
over here and this is something that I
wasn't originally planning to do but
then I let the research go a little bit
more and ended up getting the water
coasters so I thought it would be really
cool to just build one
partly also because I've been getting
some comments that you know why I why
haven't I built any water rights yet
it's it's a pretty cool category with
all the log flumes and all of that stuff
and I'm sort of missing out on that
action so far so I wanted to try
something like that and also you know I
wasn't planning to do anything with the
Oasis in the middle of the park but
looking at the layouts I figured that it
actually perfectly fits the layout of
one of these rides where you get this
little airtime Hill before you drop into
the the splashdown and it just about
fits over the path as well so you get
some really cool path interaction you
get these sections we can watch the the
ride go you get one section way to sort
of walk underneath it and then next to
the swinging ship we've got the
splashdown which is not the best thing
ever it's definitely something that you
want to try and get like some actual
path next to but still I think that the
layout works out really well for the
park and it definitely gives it
something of a sort of centerpiece and
you know the flagship attraction ride
partly also because guests will be more
likely to write these kinds of rides in
warm climates and yeah given the
temperature of this park I think it's a
pretty good idea to at least give the
guests some kind of way to cool down so
here's this ride and I mean aside from
that I'm not really straying from what I
was planning to do earlier so there
aren't gonna be any other rides or
buildings over the lake it's just gonna
be restricted to this and then the
station itself is just kind of off the
lake as well it's just the ride that
goes through it and it also has a bit of
an interesting pre lift section as well
which I think you can find on a lot of
these rides in real life as well it's
always nice to have sort of a small calm
floating part at the beginning of the
ride before the lift or you just go
through some scenery and you know build
up the anticipation for the the drop as
well and I don't have too much
experience on these kinds of rides but I
do always like them I think there
not as fun as log flumes I don't know
what it is I think it's like for me the
the smaller carriages of log flumes just
make them slightly more fun because it's
just you and your friends instead of 30
strangers sitting on the boats but still
these things are really cool and you get
some slight airtime on those hills as
well so that's always a good thing and
for this station I decided to be a tiny
bit more adventurous than I have been so
far so obviously I've got the the whole
thing with the arches and the dome in
the middle going but I also wanted to
try and build some minarets on the side
to really properly make this look quite
like an Arabic palace and I was
struggling for quite a bit on how I
would build these which is why I haven't
built any of these round minarets so far
but I think it works out pretty well
with the the basic shapes just kind of
stacking some of those cone shapes just
to make them look a little bit more
steep and using some other basic shapes
just to form that sort of midsection I
don't actually know the specific
terminology on these things but this is
more or less how they look and I think
it's a pretty decent approximation of
them definitely also the fanciest
building of the the park so far along
with the Eurofighter station
I suppose which I think it fits because
they are really the main two attractions
of the park and just to round up this
section just to fill in a little bit of
space here and make this sort of like
that the thrilling corner of the park if
you will I decided to build a drop tower
here but there isn't really going to be
anything else
this is just a great way to fill that
space since I believe then out of all
the rides in in the game the drop tower
has the smallest footprints it's just
3x3 which is a very tiny so it's always
one of these rides that you can sort of
fit into little spaces that you have
left over in your Park so for that
reason I think it's also good to sort of
conserve it until you run into one of
these spaces where you can't really
figure out what to do with it but you do
want to play some kind of right there
now over here I wanted to place the well
the sort of final parts of the town
setting you know I do want to make this
map really heavy on the buildings I
think this is definitely the park so far
that has had the most buildings and over
here I just wanted to round it up by
going for more of a sort of palace
garden style so all of the buildings
have a bit more of that arch action
going on and are a bit fancier and more
detailed than all of the buildings so
far and even though I'm honestly not an
expert on Arabian architecture
whatsoever I still think it works out
quite alright normally when I do these
kinds of Let's Plays in planet coaster
and stuff like that I tend to really
plan all of my stuff ahead and focus on
the scenery as much as possible
but since this is just the scenario I'm
just gonna keep it you know as as a
theme park ish as I can and just go with
the flow of what looks good and what
would work in a theme park setting so
it's not necessarily the most realistic
thing but I think it works out quite
nicely at the very least within the
layout of the park with having that sort
of fancy station of the water coaster as
well as the flying carpets ride over
here which I mean I almost forgot to put
that into the park and really it's it's
super important given the theme so I'm
glad I remembered last minute to put
that somewhere and at this time I was
actually planning on making this the
last area of the park so I just wanted
to finish this with a simple cue and
some food building with another burger
and soda stand as well but in hindsight
honestly I think it's not quite enough
so I'm gonna expand it a little bit but
more about that later right now I just
want to finish off this whole sort of
palace garden look of the magic carpet
area so really sort of fencing this off
again with all of these different walls
to separate it from the the lower level
and that is sort of the the pond area
where I didn't place any buildings and
we're just walking underneath the
coaster through a lots of vegetation and
then over here finally moving into the
the queue area which is
we're gonna get its own building with
some gardens around it just to make
everything quite fancy and hence also
why I'm moving the employee pass a
little bit around that as well and the
reason that I've kept the employee paths
around until this time is just so I
could lead them to the back doors of the
food courts which I'm gonna build next
to this queue so there was a little bit
of planning ahead in that sense and to
again provide a bit of a connection as
well for the employee part because
sometimes it's just a good thing to have
to provide some shortcuts from one part
of the park to another so in this case
it's a it's a slightly shorter route for
staff to go from this part of the park
to the entrance where a guests would
normally have to start walking down to
the year to the small lake and walking
up again to get into this part again now
at this point I also had to start
pausing the game and Lots just because I
was really afraid of reaching the goal
of the scenario already and I mean
that's not necessarily a problem I just
wanted to try to not reach it until I
was finished building the park so that's
gonna be a bit of a challenge actually
later on as you'll see but it's just
running way too well and I think it's
partly because the Eurofighter is a lot
more efficient than I thought it would
be I really thought it would have a
terrible throughput but it's making so
much money that I'm actually getting
quite a bit of profits and lots of
guests in the park already and the same
goes for the water coaster actually I
know I've just built it but from some of
the sections that I just sort of stomped
the time-lapse and let the park run and
kind of see how everything is going
it's actually an insanely popular ride
as well you can see that the queue over
there is definitely starting to fill up
quite a bit as well and overall just
doing really well
which I guess is pretty realistic
considering that the game did tell me
that's you know right like these will be
super popular in a warm climate
especially when it's as sunny as it is
over here so I think that works out
quite alright
that's that by the way I did have some
rain and I don't know if you can see it
during parts of the time-lapse I think
there was one or two occasions where
actually happened doing the time-lapse
as well there's definitely some rain as
well
but that said it's not really something
that I'm worrying about too much
honestly but it also helps that a lot of
stuff is actually covering anyway so
even in the rain this shouldn't be too
much of a problem for the park now this
final building of this whole sort of
fancier parts of the the town was
inspired by a building that I saw and
completely lost because I closed my tabs
basically I often have some tabs open
with inspiration from theme parks and
towns around the world but this was
basically inspired by an actual
marketplace building somewhere and I
think it works out quite well even if it
looks sort of Roman in what the layout
looks like and a lot of the typically
Arabian details are lacking it's
something that works out really well for
this part of the park I think and sets
the theme for this area quite nicely now
finally I wanted to move on but before I
do that let's give a quick gander at the
park again and then see how it's doing
before I finish it off all right now
here's the more or less finished Park or
at least as I was planning to do it
earlier and overall I am super happy
with it so far it's I know I'm gonna
repeat myself again here but it's my
favourite Park of the playthrough so far
really cozy everything is quite compact
and there's lots of detail and lots of
little charming areas that works out
better than I originally expected even
if it is really quite small as well but
that said I'm already super close to the
ghast core and if you look at the
entrance there's quite a few people
starting to enter the park as well so I
think honestly that I'm just gonna you
know let it run and reach the goal try
to get some more money to build
something else because really even
though the park feels more or less
finished enough I can't help but feel
like I want to build something else over
here it still feels a little bit too
empty like I feel like the park would
work a tiny bit better if there was
something over here as well and if
there's one ride that I think the park
is still liking it's a junior coaster I
know it's the same one that I've been
placing in so many different Pike's
already but it's just it's such an
important part of the park and even
though the scenario is pretty much
finished at this point I like this map
too much to just
let it go I want to let it go once I
feel like it's finished
you know that's nothing's actually
finished and there's just a point where
you feel like you're you're done with it
and honestly I don't really feel that
way with this map yet so I'm just gonna
reach this goal and get a sort of bonus
right in here I expand the park a little
bit more over here got some sort of
wooden bridge connect that to a small
building of the the wooden or of the
junior coaster station building here and
try to work out a bit of a layouts maybe
alongside the lake its hiney bit but
yeah at least something to give this
this park a final ride and round up the
roster of rides pretty well that aside
I'm really happy with it
and I know I haven't zoomed in too much
on some of the areas of the park but I
definitely think this park deserves a
little bit of zooming in on stuff but
for now I'm just gonna let it play to
see what this will look like hold on
didn't I just reach the goal oh yeah
right I need to hold them for three
weeks okay so that's that's gonna be
fine
just because I need to keep the
happiness rating at least 75% for three
weeks but I've got the guest call so
that's pretty good
so we've got that sort of Main Street
then we've got the little area over here
with the Eurofighter station and again
this ride is super popular so there's
always a queue for it which is also kind
of handy if it rains you know this thing
is not gonna not have any visitors
anymore but it definitely could be more
efficient than it is with a mid-course
brake run but that said there's not even
too much to complain about it makes
quite a bit of money considering the
efficiency and it's a really fun ride to
follow actually actually the following
the next rain that comes along and then
we've got the area with the swinging
ship and the drop tower over here next
to the lake which is all quite nice and
of course the water coaster over here
and this doesn't have too many boats
either so it's not the best when it
comes to efficiency it's definitely not
making as much money as the other
coaster in fact I'm asking nine dollars
but I think I can probably ask ten for
this I don't know I'm just gonna try it
and see if the people are willing to pay
even the people who got in line for $9
Oh looks like looks like I just missed
that whatever so we've got that ride and
then rotating a little bit to see this
part of the town a bit better is always
good I think and there's not too much
here it's just another sort of
marketplace with the magic carpet ride
over here which is clinic kids ride in
this case although I have only been on
one of these in real life and I do have
to say they're more intense than they
look like the way that you were sort of
forced into your seat or out of it on
every rotation of these things
especially on the bottom of those drops
it's a really cool experience I actually
like this thing let's set the only one
that I rode was in Corona learned which
as I've heard is one of the more intense
ones I'm not sure but a really cool
experience anyway and yeah I just missed
this thing again all right I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna pay attention to
this ride over here let's see if we can
zoom in on that car yeah this one there
we go
so a steady climb for the lift Hill I
didn't put a wait for the drop as I
think yeah the regular ones don't really
do that I think actually I forgot I
think they don't not like takabisha at
least but in any case it doesn't work
with the Beyond vertical drop and I
wanted to get that in instead so we've
got the similar layouts to a lot of Euro
fighters just kind of more spread out
and over here this is a corkscrew or
exclusive super handy for making over
banked turns and stuff especially when
you're in a very tight position and then
over here a final barrel roll to end the
ride and that's it
I actually noticed also to some extent
there's a there's a little bit of hard
lining there's not really any real hard
lining in any of these rides but it
almost looks like it like looking down
from above you can you can see that the
the centre of the track is going to the
right over here as it banks which is
pretty interesting to see so it's not
quite hard lined but it also doesn't
flip over in a very uncomfortable way so
overall maybe that's part of why the
banking of the game feels decently
smooth considering that it's just a
piece by bees builder much like Roy
Costa kun
was but yeah overall it works out quite
nice quite nicely there I think
and then finally yeah there isn't too
much else to see it's really a small
park I tried to focus more on details
and getting as much and in a very tight
space as I could just to keep everything
quite close to the Oasis and make sure
that I don't have to cuddle up to the
pike borders either but I think I'll be
nice to you know get started on that
Junior coaster as a final ride and round
up the park properly so let's get
started all right now this coaster here
went through a couple of different draft
versions before I ended up settling on
the layouts which you can see right here
so even though it's gonna look as though
I got everything right right away and
super smoothly and with complete ease
that's kind of not really true I ended
up struggling with quite a few different
layouts just because I was really afraid
given that this is the the last part of
the park I always feel that pressure of
trying to finish it in a way that I'm
happy with and it kind of feels like if
I mess up on this it just kind of ruins
the rest of the park which I'm already
happy with so I was a bit nervous about
this one honestly but in the end I think
it's a decent layout and it's sort of
following the same general rules of the
junior coaster so far so really going
from left to right in different
consecutive turns in different
directions in these different helixes
and it has also that sort of you know
first part second part kind of fuel to
the layouts where the first part is
these helixes that twist in and out of
each other and ii just kind of flows
down the hill and goes more in a sort of
out in bank fashion I don't know I
always like it when they have that sort
of general feel to the layout
especially since this is market X you
know what the coaster looks like from
above is almost more importance than
what it looks like from the side as a
layouts so that's definitely something
that sort of makes my layouts different
in this game than in say planet coaster
for instance now for this station I
basically did what I advise people to
never do and just build a rectangle and
trying to dress it up as nicely as I
could or it should turn out to be a
little bit difficult especially given
the theme which is already quite
minimalistic but I think considering the
case it's not too much of an issue since
this is just the station for a junior
coaster which tend to not be as well
dressed up as other coasters in many
parks since it's just a really small
ride for the families somewhere on the
edge of the park so really not all that
important so I think it's all right I
also wanted to add some of these
catwalks on the side of the lift Hill
and that turned out to be a bit of a
struggle because trying to get
everything on the grid
and trying to make sure that actually
had some fences on it was a bit
difficult so I ended up going for this
technique where I'm trying to put the
fences down on terrain and then remove
the terrain again and that ended up not
really completely fitting to the
catwalks which I built earlier so had to
go through a couple of different
versions of that one but in the end I
think it works alright I won't be adding
catwalks to all of the coasters but you
know when when I can and when it sort of
fits the theme I think it's nice to add
it and apart from these fences which
were a bit of an issue these catwalks
are also honestly quite easy to build
I've got a few questions on what kind of
pieces I'm using to built them but it's
just the small roof tiles you can use
half tile roof tiles for this I'm using
the sort of handguard style
I think that's an eighth of a grid space
tile on the side and then just corners
pieces and fences to make the sort of
fence on the side I'm also using some
roof pieces to connect these catwalks to
the supports which you can see there
which kind of look like the real life
supports or the connectors that you know
connect the catwalks and the supports so
I think that works alright as well and
then finally I'm putting a lot of trees
and foliage in here especially around
the station which is inspired by a
quotes that I can't believe I've never
mentioned on my channel because I always
talk about how you can use foliage to
make your buildings look better or how
if you have a building that you're not
happy with you can just put some trees
around it and it'll instantly look
better which is very similar to a quote
by frank lloyd wright's
I think it was a doctor can bury his
mistakes but an architect can only
advise the client to plant vines which
pretty much works just putting for
around your buildings makes them look
nicer but yeah that's basically it for
this park so let's give it one final
overview and call it a day nice so we're
almost there and I just realized that my
trick with the terraforming actually
reset itself when I loaded the park
again it's not something I I'm not gonna
try again I'm just gonna remove the
fences and leave it at that but yeah
this is basically the coaster and in the
meantime we should get the goals there
we go and I'm just gonna do one quick
tour through the park again
and then we're finally gonna head over
into the next scenario and I don't think
I'll be getting any new ones because I
didn't completely non-optional girls by
the end of March year two in fact it's
already year four again it's not too bad
but yeah I think that means that I'll be
doing the I forgot what the next
scenario was but there's already one
more that I got so it's probably gonna
be that one and let's check because I
didn't do a POV of the water coaster yet
now I'm just gonna let this run and just
pick another boats because this is
already going down but it's probably fun
to see at least where this thing is
gonna go and what that whole track is
gonna end up looking like and we're just
gonna have to wait for this thing to
start there we go
and actually click on the ride instead
of one guests and that's the one we want
to have so there's a bit of interesting
interaction I think going on over here
where you're going past the where the
heads are clipping through the bridge as
well I never actually bother to check
that as well
but uh yeah that's a thing I've got
actually got a comments on the last
video as well on why a lot of the
vehicles for many of the rides and the
coasters are quite large if you compare
them to the real knife counterparts and
it's really just because of the cartoony
style of the game that the guests are so
big that pretty much the vehicles have
to fit their bodies but in this case I
feel like raising the raising the
clearance on this coaster might be a
good idea from
one for grid space to one and a half or
something like that because that bridge
was clipping a little bit too much but
yeah it's basically a basically a quick
simple right like this I don't like it a
lot and actually it works really well if
I'm gonna be completely honest I think
this rendition of the ride works much
better than the planet coaster one
because this one allows you to drop into
the water and whatever kind of you know
transition you want so I made this one
quite smooth but you can also make it
less or more smooth and in planet
coaster you pretty much just are stuck
with a single angle for the drop so this
one honestly I think works a little bit
better but I'm just gonna have to watch
out with this actually because I put
this path down way too low I thought it
was okay but apparently I really should
have checked that but yeah that's
honestly I don't really mind either
because I didn't even notice it until I
wrote the ride so I don't think it's too
much of an issue I like the path too
much to actually remove this yeah that's
basically that's and then the rest of
the the rest of the park is all just
stalls and stuff like this I think I'm
gonna go for this for the eat thumbnail
though just because it works out way too
well but yeah that's it for mystic Oasis
I'm just gonna leave the park right here
I saved it just before I reach the goals
so actually speaking of which you have
to start uploading my stuff and I'm also
going to look if I can upload any of
these blueprints but given that they are
quite terrain conforming I don't know if
I'll be doing that but for the next one
oh we're actually already getting
another scenario I wasn't expecting that
okay so we've got the the whole island
situation here and I think yeah that's
the one but I'm gonna do Nova Labs first
because I mean I got that first I think
it's fair to try this one next and to be
honest I know what this one looks like
obviously because I've seen all these
scenarios before and even though the
theme is very sci-fi ish I recently saw
some people build some steampunk
inspired builds and
honestly I am really tempted to try and
go for some kind of sci-fi steampunk
theme in this park that said it is all
gonna depend on what kind of scenery
pieces we get in the park which I don't
yet know but it's just something that I
suppose I'm gonna brood over until I
start that episode in any case thanks
for watching mystic oasis and hopefully
I'll see you next time on Nova lamps bye
guys